[Música]
balanceándose en el desértico suelo
australiano esta ornito rinco hembra
Busca agua fresca durante años una
severa sequía convirtió ríos y arroyos
en simples chorritos ella sobrevivió
pero no pudo reproducirse podrá en el
siguiente año cambiar la
suerte es otoño y las gotas de lluvia
caen del
cielo dentro de unos días la
ornitorrinco encuentra un río y empieza
a cazar sus patas la impulsan y su
pelaje a prueba de agua atrapa el calor
cerca de su
cuerpo bajo el agua siente su alrededor
con su cola pico de pato equipada con
casi 40.000 electrorreceptores esto le
permite detectar hasta la más mínima
señal eléctrica de nervios y músculos de
un camarón ella lo convierte en comida
rápida y al volver a subir a la tierra
para construir una madriguera camina
como lagarto sus patas moviéndose
horizontalmente hacia su
espina el ornitorrinco tiene muchas
rarezas como un monotrema es parte del
más antiguo linaje de mamíferos vivos
Por ende tiene una mezcla curiosa de
rasgos mamíferos aviares y reptiles lo
cual se refleja en su
genoma por ejemplo los mamíferos tienen
un par de cromosomas que definen su sexo
pero el ornitorinco tiene cinco que se
asemejan más a los de las aves esperemos
que los pueda
utilizar ella recupera su fuerza y
cuando llega la primavera es hora de
aparearse pero no puede criar a sus
crías aquí la tierra ha comenzado a ser
deforestada haciendo que la orilla se
erosione en su lugar va río arriba y se
queda en un estanque protegido por un
Eucalipto
rojo de repente un ruido espanta a las
aves de la maleza y un zorro
aparece estos depredadores amenazan a
los ornitos rincos desde que fueron
introducidos a Australia por los
europeos en
1855 el zorro no la ve esta vez Pero el
ornitorrinco debe estar
alerta dos Machos También ocupan esta
y empezarán a competir por su
afecto cada uno tiene espolones en sus
patas Con un fuerte veneno como el de
las víboras los machos pelean entre sí y
cortejan a la hembra por varias semanas
nadando cerca de ella y ocasionalmente
mordiendo su
cola ella hace lo mismo y nadan en
círculos antes de hacer el acto el macho
ornitorrinco tiene un pene con
características excéntricas como dos
cabezas y espinas que ayudan a la
fertilización tras la siguiente semana
la hembra construye una madriguera bien
preparada ella tapa los túneles que
llevan al lugar y los Deja como puntos
muertos para potenciales
depredadores Entonces como un reptil o
ave ella Deja los huevos desde su cloaca
una entrada que se usa para la
reproducción y
excreción incuba sus huevos y mientras
el Eucalipto rojo
su descendencia
nace como otros mamíferos les da
leche pero no tiene
pezones en lugar de pezones su leche
sale de unas glándulas mamarias en su
vientre donde sus bebés la
sorben la leche almacenada atrae
bacterias pero el ornitorrinco produce
una potente proteína
antibacterial ella continúa cuidándolos
por cuatro meses casa evade a los zorros
y repara su madriguera al mismo tiempo
cuando sus bebés estén listos el verano
está
terminado una tarde cuando la hembra
ornitorrinco regrese de cazar se dará
cuenta que un polluelo ya habrá dejado
el
nido unos días después el otro también
dejará el nido pronto sus bebés vivirán
independientemente y eventualmente ellos
dejarán en esta parte del río para hacer
sus propios
hogares Apenas ha contemplado todas las
criaturas extrañas y maravillosas que
vagan por el planeta eche un vistazo a
la mente de un elefante y conozca su
increíble inteligencia con este video o
con este video Explore las asombrosas
capacidades del hocico de su
perro